one of the biggest surprises of Rise of
the beasts was undoubtedly the reveal in
the film's final moments as Noah
continues to look for security work
following his adventure with the
Autobots he comes across a man named
agent Burke who cryptically indicates
that he knows everything that's been
going on he knows all about Noah's time
with the autobots and wants him to join
his secret team in this scene it's tough
to figure out who Burke is or what
organization he works for then as Noah
looks into the secret lab behind the
wall and flips over the card we get the
surprising reveal that Burke is part of
GI Joe now it's not totally out of the
realm of possibility for these two
franchises to have an epic crossover
especially since it's happened before GI
Joe and Transformers have crossed paths
multiple times in the comics and they're
both toy brands under Hasbro plus
Paramount has produced films for both
franchises the GI Joe films haven't
found the same success that Transformers
has at the box office so maybe Paramount
thinks a crossover could benefit both
franchises regardless it's still an epic
Easter egg that teases a potentially
amazing mashup